the uk has issued just 50 visas to
ukrainians so far when more than a
million people have fled the country are
you happy with that number i'm not sure
those numbers are right but we're
processing thousands as i uh as i speak
to you and clearly this
this crisis is evolving the whole time
and i've i've said before that the uk
will be
as generous as we can possibly be and we
intend to to to do that we have two very
very generous routes already so the
family reunion route which is uncapped
which could potentially see hundreds of
thousands of people come to this country
plus there's a humanitarian route and
under that scheme people can sponsor
people uh coming from ukraine uh we're
surging officials into the the border
countries to help people to come
so uh to to poland to bulgaria to
romania also to to france uh and uh
clearly what's happening now is that
putin is doubling down
on his aggression
and he is
deciding to attack in a pretty
indiscriminate way that's producing
huge waves of people we're going to have
to respond to that and we will we've
always been very generous in the way we
respond to uh people fleeing uh war
zones and no country in europe has done
more to settle vulnerable people uh
since 2015 that than the uk you say it's
not 50 how many then prime minister i
can't give you the number we're
processing thousands uh right now we
will continue
to make sure that we have a very very
generous approach what we what are you
considering
are you considering a third route not
based on family members not based on
sponsorship similar to the eu scheme
what we won't do let me be very clear
what we won't do is have a system where
people can come into
the uk without any checks or any
controls at all i don't think that is
the right approach but what we will do
is have a system that is very very
generous as the situation in in ukraine
deteriorates people are going to want to
see this country open our arms to people
fleeing persecution fleeing awards and i
think people who have spare rooms who uh
who want to receive people coming from
ukraine will want us to uh to have a
system that enables them he's had to do
that
that is that is already happening so so
what we will do is have a very very
generous and
an open approach but what we won't do is
simply abandon controls altogether and
there are very good reasons for that if
you look at the
the situation in the eu they have a as
you know they have a border-free zone in
schengen they can't actually
impose controls even if they they wanted
to we have a different system and i
think it's sensible given what's going
on in ukraine to make sure that we have
some basic ability to check who is
coming in and who isn't but if you look
at the record of this government just uh
since i've been prime minister you know
we've taken uh more than 15 000 people
under op pitting for afghanistan we've
had 104 000 people apply from from hong
kong uh coming in fear of uh uh coming
to take advantage of the british
nationals overseas a scheme from from
hong kong and we are a very very
generous country what we want though is
control and we want to be able to have
checks okay did you intervene to secure
agronomy lebadev a peerage when you
discover the security service services
thought he posed a national security
threat
that is simply incorrect but what i can
tell you is that you didn't intervene
what i can tell you is that it suits
putin's agenda
to try to characterize
this as a
a struggle between the west and and
russia and it suits his agenda to say
that uh
the uk that uh
we in the we in
in nato countries
are anti-russian or european countries
are now anti-russian and it's very very
very important that we get the message
over that we're not anti-russian we're
not against russians
we're simply we our quarrel is simply
with the with the regime
and the aggression of vladimir putin of
course but if the security services
deemed him a risk and you intervened to
give him a peerage well that would
obviously be extraordinary but that's
that's so you did not do
did you meet with him in march 2020 at
the height of the pandemic to discuss
giving him a peerage listen uh it is
very very important
it is very very it's it is very very
important
that the
uh
this should not turn into a general uh
sense that we're against russians uh any
russian living in the in the uk any
russian who contributes to a uk society
should suddenly be under
suspicion
that is that suits putin's agenda he's
going to want to frame this as a
conflict between russia and the west
this is this is about the ukrainian
people their struggle against a a
murderous attack on their liberty and a
murderous and a violent attack on cities
in ukraine that have done absolutely
nothing to deserve it and we must not
play putin's game and somehow turn this
into a
a a
a witch hunt against every russian in
the in the uk it's absolutely vital we
focus on what putin is doing and we call
him out for what he's doing and what
we're doing today what i'm doing today
if i can just explain is i've got the
uh the
leaders of
holland and uh and canada justin trudeau
of canada mark rutter of holland here
with me right now
later on i'll be talking to joe biden
and and other and other colleagues
about what we can do to bring the west
together and to keep the west together
because i think the the unity of the
west has been
uh
very very strong
during this period it's been something
that i don't think uh
putin bargained for but
now that he is
going for this
really unrestrained attack on
on on cities now that he's attacking
civilians in the way that he is i think
we've got to recognize that we've got to
do more on sanctions and there is more
we can do and more that i think we we
should do so on
swift there's more that the world cur
can do uh on banking there's more that
the world can do and i think that there
is more to be done on uh on sanctioning
individuals so that's why we're bringing
in the economic measures under the
economic economic crime bill uh today
and and targeting individuals ask your
final question on saturday labour say
you're giving oligarchs a get out of
london free card by allowing companies
six months to register they want to see
it cuts in like 28 days what do you
review that time period we want to go
we want to go as fast as we possibly can
but i don't think anybody looking at
what is going on at the moment could
credibly say that the uk has been a a
back marker in this don't forget we were
the first country in europe to
offer military assistance to the
ukrainians for their own self-defense uh
we were the country that led the the
world on uh on swift on freezing the
assets of the russian central bank look
at the impact that that is happening
that that is having already in uh in
russia their stock market isn't uh still
isn't isn't open uh today uh i think
that they weren't uh expecting the the
levels of western unity and the the
extent of the sanctions that we're
imposing there's more to be done uh we
certainly want to go as fast as possible
that's why i've got the the
mark rutter and justin trudeau with me
today and others and others today
we'll be well nothing nothing nothing is
off is off the table and we'll be
talking about all of that later today
thank you thank you